[Musik]
1916 nur 13 Jahre nachdem die Gebrüder
Wright ihren ersten Jungfernflug mit
einem Flugzeug schwerer als luftwah
absolviert hatten wurde ein
amerikanisches Unternehmen gegründet
dass die noch junge luftfahtindustrie
revolutionieren sollte gegründet als
Pacific Aero products und nur ein Jahr
später in Boeing umbenannt war das
Unternehmen jahrzehntelang erfolgreich
und entwickelt einige der besten
Technologien und viele der besten
Flugzeuge der Zeit vom ersten modernen
Verkehrsflugzeug der Boeing 247 die 1933
auf den Markt kam bis zum kultigen Jumbo
747 konnte Boeing die Menschheit
jahrzehnteelang im Erstaunen versetzen
tja bis Airbus kam
90 Jahre nach dem Start der kultigen
Boeing 247 sieht die Welt der Luftfahrt
heute ganz anders aus Boeing ist nicht
nur kein Marktführer mehr nein er wurde
auch noch von einem Konk konurrenten
überholt der fast halb so alt ist wie er
Airbus werf mal einen Blick auf diese
Grafik was ihr hier sehen könnt ist ein
hart umkämpfter Kriegsschauplatz ein
Markt der zwischen zwei Giganten
aufgeteilt ist wobei Airbus jetzt die
Führung übernommen hat in den letzten 20
Jahren hat Airbus in Europa mehr
Aufträge erhalten als sein
nordamerikanischer Konkurrent und die
Frage lautet warum wie ist es möglich
dass die Europäer es geschafft haben die
mächtige amerikanische kommerzielle
Flugzeugindustrie zu schlagen viele von
euch werden vielleicht denken dass diese
Wende viel mit dem fiasco der Boeing 737
MAX zu tun hat eine Flugzeug das 20
Monate lang am Boden blieb weil die
Flugsicherheitsbehörden nach zwei
tödlichen Abstürzen ein Flugverbot
verhängt hatten und ja in gewisser Weise
hat das viel mit dem zu tun was damals
passiert ist schließlich war die 737 ma
die große Hoffnung Boeings aber nein das
ist nicht der einzige Grund warum Airbus
es geschafft hat seinen US Rivalen zu
überholen in diesem Fall reicht die
Geschichte viel weiter
zurück
ich meine habt ihr euch jemals gefragt
wie es ausgerechnet einem europäischen
Flugzeughersteller gelingen konnte in
Sachen Qualität und Technologie mit dem
großen amerikanischen Marktführer
gleichzuziehen der diese Branche
praktisch von Anfang an beherrschte wie
ist Airbus entstanden wessen Idee war es
und warum wurde es überhaupt gegründet
wer hat das ganze Geld aufgebracht damit
es gegen einen riesigen Konkurrenten wie
Boeing überhaupt eine Chance haben kann
und vielleicht die wichtigste Frage von
allen was in aller Welt hat das mit
visualpolitik zu t nun die Geschichte
von Airbus und seinem Krieg mit Boeing
ist nicht nur eine Geschichte des
Wettbewerbs zwischen zwei Unternehmen
sondern auch eine Geschichte des
politischen Wettbewerbs die Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika gegen die
Europäische Union der alte Riese gegen
den neuen Titanen und glaubt mir wenn
ich euch verrate dass diese Geschichte
extrem vielschichtig ist und unglaublich
viele spannende Facetten berei hält vor
allem geht sie weit über das Fliegen
selbst hinaus na seid ihr gespannt dann
dürftet ihr euch auch auf unseren
heutigen Sponsor freuen denn jetzt
präsentiere ich euch ein Spiel das nicht
nur Adrenalin pur bietet sondern auch
strategisches Denken erfordert es spielt
sich nicht in der Luft ab sondern vor
allem auf dem Wasser sein Name world of
warships ganz genau das legendäre world
of warships feiert nämlich seinen achten
Geburtstag mit einem Knall dieses
fantastische kostenlose PC-Spiel bietet
euch teambasierte Seeschlachten bei
denen jede Strategie und Taktik zählt
ihr könnt mit euren Freunden in
Divisionen spielen und gemeinsam in die
Schlacht mit über 600 historischen
Schiffen und 13 verschiedenen Nationen
habt ihr nicht nur eine riesige Auswahl
nein jedes Schiff basiert auch noch auf
wirklich authentischen Entwürfen und
Blaupausen aus dem 20 Jahrhundert und
gehört zu einer von fünf Klassen
Zerstörer Kreuzer Schlachtschiffe
Flugzeugträger und U-Boote und eines
kann ich euch versichern jede dieser
Klassen bietet mit ihren spezifischen
Charakteristika ein einzigartiges
Spielerlebnis aber das beste ihr könnt
eure Schiffe auch noch nach Belieben
castomisen hinzu kommt die atenbauenden
Grafiken und lebendigen Landschaften
sind nicht nur ein wahrer Augenschmauß
nein sie sorgen auch für eine
unglaublich packende Atmosphäre und an
dieser Stelle müsst ihr mir einen
kleinen dead Joke erlauben denn durch
diese dichte maritime Atmosphäre könnt
ihr so richtig ins Spielerlebnis der
Seeschlachten abtauchen ihr versteht
schon abtauchen okay ich habe euch ja
gewarnt ein dead Joke aber mal im Ernst
Spieler wie Kritiker lieben wde warships
für seine historische Authentizität mit
detailgetreu nachgebildeten Schiffen das
strategische und teamorientierte
Gameplay sowie die actionreichen und
spannenden Gefechte ein großartiges
Spiel für alle Fans von online
multiplayer Seeschlachten trotz
minimaler Kritik am leichten pay to win
Modell bietet world of warships ein
umfangreiches qualitativ hochwertiges
und kostenloses Spielerlebnis und um
seinen achten Geburtstag Gebühren zu
feiern haben wir ein besonderes Angebot
für alle neuspiele wenn ihr euch über
den Link in der Beschreibung registriert
erhaltet ihr ein bombiges Starterpaket
im Wert von 25 €. dieses enthält 500
Dublonen 7 Tage Premiumzugang 2
Millionen Credits ein Schiff der Stufe 4
und einen Kommandanten mit sechs
Fähigkeitspunkten und damit erhaltet ihr
gleich von Einfang kostenlos einen
riesen Vorsprung aber bealt euch dieses
Angebot gilt nur für Neuspieler die sich
zum ersten Mal auf dem Wargaming Portal
registrieren und schaut euch bitte auch
das spezielle jubiläumsvideo an das wir
für euch bereitgestellt haben denn jetzt
ist die beste Zeit in die Welt der
Seeschlachten einzutauchen also klickt
auf den Link in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video registriert euch und
startet mit einem mächtigen
Vorteilspaket in eurer Karriere in der
Kriegsmarine bis bald auf hoher se
Kapitäne so und nun schnallt Euch gut an
und lasst uns vom Wasser in die Luft
abheben auf
[Musik]
geht's Stärke durch
Einigkeit die zweite Hälfte des 20
Jahrhunderts war das Zeitalter des
wirtschaftlichen Booms und der Moderne
sowohl im Westen als auch in weiten
Teilen Asiens und es war auch die Zeit
in der sich Europa aus der Asche des
Zweiten Weltkriegs erhob wo es früher
ständige Kämpfe und Konflikte gegeben
hatte herrschte jetzt plötzlich
Einigkeit und Zusammenarbeit und wenn
das nicht der Fall gewesen wäre hätte es
Airbus wahrscheinlich nie
[Musik]
gegeben das europäische
Luftfahrtunternehmen schlechthin wurde
1970 gegründet es war das Ergebnis einer
politischen Verhandlung zwischen den
Regierungen die bereits einige Jahre
zuvor begonnen hatte ja genau Airbus ist
nicht etwa der geniale Einfall eines
visionären unternehm oder so etwas in
der Art die Idee stammt viel mehr aus
den Büros der französischen und
westdeutschen Regierungen in den
späteren 1960er Jahren um ihre Ziele zu
erreichen förderten diese Regierungen
den Zusammenschluss der großen
Luftfahrtunternehmen in ihren Ländern in
Frankreich war dies der Konzern
aerospaial Matra und in Deutschland die
DASA die Daimler Benz Aerospace
Aktiengesellschaft dem Konsortium
schlossen sich später
Luftfahrtunternehmen aus Spanien und den
Vereinigten Königreich an im
Wesentlichen ging es darum jene
Kooperation zu wiederholen die die
Franzosen und Britten einig ige Jahre
zuvor bei der Entwicklung der Concord
eingegangen waren aber in diesem Fall
mit dem Ziel eine langfristige Struktur
zu schaffen die es ermöglichen würde
Flugzeuge zu bauen die sagen wir mal
weniger exklusiv sind Flugzeuge die
zunächst in der Lage sein mussten eine
Nische zu füllen in der die
amerikanischen Unternehmen Boeing lockit
und McDonald Douglas die etwa 80% des
Marktes beherrschen kein Produkt hatten
und später nachdem dies gelungen war
auch im großen Stil direkt mit Ihnen zu
konkurrieren und so kam es dass das
erste Flugzeug das auf den Markt kam der
Airbus A300 war das erste
Großraumflugzeug das mit zwei
Triebwerken unter et-top Standards
kommerzielle Flüge
durchführte und als es den Europäern
gelungen war moderne Flugzeuge
herzustellen und dank der Fusion
mehrerer Unternehmen immer mehr
Marktanteile zu gewinnen musste Boeing
etwas unternehmen also versuchte der
amerikanische Riese 1997 das europäische
Modell zu kopieren indem er seinen
direkten Konkurrenten in den USA
McDonald Douglas Übernahme mit dieser
Akquisition erbte der amerikanische
Riese jedoch so einige Probleme des
Unternehmens dass es geschluckt
hatte darunter waren wirtschaftliche und
unternehmenskulturelle Probleme die
früher oder später ihren Tribut fordern
würden denn mit dem aggressiv
vertriebsgetriebenen McDonald Douglas
hatte das eher ingenieursorientierte
Boeing eine wahre Giftpille geschluckt
das extrem selbstbewusste und
Durchsetzung starke Management von
McDonald Douglas setzte sich nämlich
kurzer Hand an die Spitze des
Gesamtkonzerns die eher schüchternen
introvertierten und kopflastigen
Ingenieure und ihre Manager von Boeing
wurden in den Hintergrund gedrängt und
damit nahmen die Katastrophe ihren Lauf
denn ihr müsst eines verstehen diese
Branche ist sehr kapitalintensiv das
heißt man muss eine Menge Geld
investieren damit sie überhaupt
funktioniert und wie euch vorstellen
könnt ist es nicht leicht Flugzeuge zu
entwerfen zu entwickeln und herzustellen
es handelt sich um eine äußerst komplexe
genau
ingenieurstätigkeit und die Frage war
wer würde all das Geld aufbringen um die
technolog zu entwickeln mit der jedes
der beiden Unternehmen versuchen würde
den Markt zu erobern denn zum ersten Mal
hatte Boeing einen potenziellen
riesenvorsicht der ihm auf Augenhöhe
begegnen konnte aber wie genau würden
sie konkurrieren wie wollten die
Europäer den US-Giganten in den Schatten
stellen ich sag's noch einmal um ein
neues flugzeugprogramm zu starten
braucht man vor allem zwei Dinge das
erste ist Geld und das zweite extrem
viel Geld aber um euch eine klare
Vorstellung davon zu geben wovon wir
hier sprechen lasst uns mal ein
konkretes Beispiel nehmen lst einen
Blick auf den Fall des Airbus A380
werfen das ist immerhin das größte
Verkehrsflugzeug der Welt dessen
Produktion allerdings im März 2021
eingestellt wurde aber gut seht euch mal
das folgende
an die Kosten für das A380 Programm den
gesamten Entwicklungszyklus von der Idee
bis zur indienstellung umfasst wurden im
Jahr 2000 ursprünglich auf rund 11,3
Milliarden Dollar geschätzt nach
heutigen Schätzungen verschlang die
Entwicklung dieses himmelsriesen jedoch
weit mehr als als 30 Milliarden Dollar
und ihr merkt schon das sind wahrlich
astronomische
zahlen und bedenk bitte dass Airbus
selbst zugibt dass der A380 die
Gewinnzone nie erreicht hat bis zum
Zeitpunkt der Einstellung seiner
Produktion sind also viele viele
Milliarden Euro verloren gegangen und
hier kommen wir zum zweiten Punkt den
man braucht um ein neues Flugzeug auf
den Markt zu bringen neben Geld muss
natürlich auch ausreichend Nachfrage
vorhanden sein angesichts der Zahlen um
die es geht könnten schlechte Prognosen
die wicklung des neuen Flugzeugs in ein
Disaster verwandeln nun und genau an
dieser Stelle kommen wir zum
kontroversesten Teil dieses Duells der
Titanen und die Frage lautet was hat
Airbus besser gemacht als die Amerikaner
nun aus Sicht vieler Amerikaner ist das
was Europa mit Airbus gemacht hat nichts
anderes als unlauterer Wettbewerb eine
Situation die sogar einen Handelskrieg
zwischen den Vereinigten Staaten und dem
europäischen Block ausgelöst hat se euch
an USA und EU einigen sich auf
Aussetzung des handelsstreits zwischen
Airbus und Boeing der 17-Jährige
Handelsstreit ist der längste und
kostspieligste in der Geschichte der
Welthandelsorganisation WTO nach Angaben
der US Zollbehörde US Customs and border
protection haben die us-importeure seit
in krafttreten der Zölle im Jahr 2019
mehr als 1,1 Milliarden Dollar an Zöllen
gezahlt aber wollt ihr genau wissen
worum es bei diesem Konflikt geht und
warum er überhaupt entstanden ist ist
Airbus wirklich nur dank der
Vorzugsbehandlung durch die europäischen
Regierungen gewachsen ist alles nur
künstlich handelt es sich um einen Fall
von unlauterem Wettbewerb und was spielt
sich während der ganzen Zeit in den USA
ab nun das werden wir jetzt genau unter
die Lupe
[Musik]
nehmen Krieg der
Egos der Handelsstreit zwischen den USA
und der Europäischen Union sowie
zwischen Boeing und Airbus mit der
Welthandelsorganisation in der Mitte
hatte eine ganz klare Ursache die
Finanzierung der europäische
flugzeugherstelle Airbus erhält seit
seiner Gründung große Mengen an
staatlichen Geldern um die Kosten für
die Entwicklung neuer Flugzeuge zu
decken aber schauen wir uns dazu ein
paar Fakten an im Laufe der Geschichte
dieses Konsortiums haben die Regierungen
Frankreichs Deutschlands des Vereinigten
Königreichs und Spaniens zu denen sich
später noch weitere Länder gesellten
tonnenweise Geld zugeschossen staatliche
Gelder sowohl in Form von direkten
Subventionen als auch in Form von
Krediten zu künstlich niedrigen
Zinssätzen oder gar ganz zinslos wir
sprechen über Beihilfen die 15
Milliarden Dollar übersteigen könnten
deren Auswirkungen auf den Markt sich
aber nach einigen Schätzungen auf 200
Milliarden Dollar belaufen könnten was
sich logischerweise gegen Boeing in den
Vereinigten Staaten richtet all diese
Mittel werden als Starthilfe bezeichnet
und bilden einen der größten
industriepolitischen Pläne Europas
während der letzten
[Musik]
Jahrzehnte im Grunde genommen haben die
europäischen Staaten diese Instrumente
genutzt um einen erheblichen Teil der
Kosten für die Entwicklung der ersten
airbusmodelle wie dem A300 oder der
mittelgroßen Flugzeugfamilie wie dem
A320 der mit der Boeing 737 konkurriert
zu decken der Konflikt entsteht weil die
Subventionen ursprünglich reduziert
werden sollten bis sie mit der marktreif
von Airbus verschwinden und auch weil
sie eigentlich vollständig zurückgezahlt
werden müssten wenn jedes einzelne
Programm Gewinn
abwirft mit anderen Worten das
Unternehmen sollte mit dem Geld der
europäischen Steuerzahler unterstützt
werden während es mit der Erwartung
startete später einen höheren Gewinn zu
erzielen im Grunde handelt es sich um
einen typischen industriepolitischen
Plan den viele von euch sicher positiv
sehen wden schließlich war Airbus ein
großer Erfolg und ihr denkt vielleicht
auch dass es besser ist öffentliche
Mittel für Initiativen wie diese zu
verwenden als für andere sagen wir mal
abstraktes viel weniger produktives Zeug
natürlich gebe es zu diesem Thema noch
viel zu sagen aber das ist eher ein
Thema für unseren schwesterkanal visual
konomic wie euch vorstellen können sind
die Amerikaner darüber jedenfalls nicht
glücklich noch weniger wenn man bedkt
dass diese Finanzhilfe wieder
verschwunden ist noch Airbus die
gesamten Kredite jemals zurückgezahlt
hat 6 März 2019 Airbus im Streit um 600
Millionen US-Dollar an nicht
zurückgezahlten Krediten für die
Entwicklung des A380 laut Reus behauptet
Airbus dass es keine ausstehenden
staatlichen Darlehen für den A380 mehr
zurückzahlen muss weil die Regierungen
zugestimmt haben das Risiko für das rund
15 Milliarden Euro teure Projekt zu
übernehmen wie ihr seht waren diese
stadthilfen dermaßen vorteilhaft dass
sie offenbar eine Klausel enthielten
nach der das Risiko zwischen den
Kreditgebern also den Regierungen und
dem Empfänger geteilt wurde wenn das
Programm schiefging mit anderen Worten
Airbus und die Staaten würden sich zwar
die Verluste teilen aber die Gewinne
würden allein Airbus zufallen es ist die
alte Geschichte Verluste werden
sozialisiert Gewinne privatisiert ich
meine es ist ja nicht so dass Airbus
Geld verliert klar das A380 Programm ist
etwas schlecht gelaufen aber das
Unternehmen insgesamt ist auf dem Weg
nach oben im Jahr 2022 hat der Konzern
z.B ein Nettogewinn nachsteuern von mehr
als 4,2 Milliarden Euro erwirtschaftet
das beste Ergebnis in seiner gesamten
Geschichte trotzdem wurde ein Teil der
Verluste beim A380 Programm von den
europäischen Ländern aufgefangen und um
ehrlich zu sein weiß ich nicht welchen
Sinn das macht und die Amis sind
überhaupt nicht amused die Wut dort ist
gewaltig und zwar sowohl in der
boeingzentrale als auch bei den
Politikern in
washingten ihrer Meinung nach haben die
Europäer die amerikanische
Flugzeugindustrie mit angeblich
illegalen Beihilfen torpediert und die
Welthandelsorganisation kam dann
schließlich zum Schluss dass derartig
Kredite an Airbus tatsächlich unlauteren
Wettbewerb darstellen tja die Amis
hatten also nicht ganz unrecht um
Frieden mit Washington zu schließen und
die BTO rechtlen einzuhalten mussten die
Europäische Union Frankreich und Spanien
Zinssätze für Kredite an Airbus im
Zusammenhang mit der Einführung des A350
erhöhen tja und als wären das nicht
genug Beweise dafür dass die Europäer
nichts als Schurken sind kam dann auch
noch ein gigantischer Korruptionsskandal
und Airbus wurde zu gigantischen
Strafzahlungen verurteilt
31 Januar 2020 Airbus stimmt der Zahlung
von über 3,9 Milliarden Dollar an
globalen Strafen zu um bestechungsfälle
im Ausland und Verstöße gegen
internationale Regeln für den
Waffenhandel beizulegen Airbus war an
einem mehrjährigen und massiven Plan zur
korrupten Förderung seiner
geschätftsinteressen beteiligt indem es
in China und anderen Ländern
Schmiergelder zahlte und diese
Schmiergelder verbarg heute hat Airbus
eine jahrelange korruptionskampagne auf
der ganzen Welt zugegeben Airbus se das
zweitgrößte Luft und
Raumfahrtunternehmen der Welt war an
einer systematischen vorsätzlich
Verschwörung beteiligt die wissentlich
und vorsätzlich gegen die
US-amerikanischen Betrugs und
exportgesetze verstieß der betrugck und
die Bestechung von Airbus bei
kommerziellen flugzeuggeschäften stärkte
korrupte Fluggesellschaften und
böswillige Akteure weltweit was auf
Kosten von ehrlichen Unternehmen ging
darüber hinaus stellte die Bestechung
von Regierungsbeamten insbesondere
derjenigen die an der Beschaffung von US
Militärtechnologie beteiligt waren eine
Bedrohung der nationalen Sicherheit für
die USA und ihre Verbündeten da okay
damit wä ja alles klar die Europäer sind
die Bösen und die Amerikaner die guten
tja wenn es so einfach wä denn wie wir
hier bei visualpitik immer betonen jede
Geschichte hat mindestens zwei Versionen
und es ist nicht gerade so als ob die
Amis sich anständig verhalten hätten
ganz und gar nicht man könnte sogar
sagen dass die US-Regierung Boeing in
den letzten Jahren aus vielen
selbstverursachten Schwierigkeiten
herausgezogen hat und zwar auf ganz
unterschiedliche Weise einige davon
übrigens mit katastrophalen Folgen
möchtet ihr wissen worüber genau wir
hier reden sollen wir dir verraten
welche schmutzigen Tricks die Amis
ausgehackt haben nun dann passt jetzt
gut
auf staatliche Rettungsaktionen unterm
ladenpult wir haben euch ja bereits
gesagt dass Airbus eine Menge Geld von
den europäischen Steuerzahlern erhalten
hat z.B Schulden die bei vielen
Gelegenheiten erlasten wurden was Boeing
in seinem Wettbewerb mit Airbus
eindeutig geschadet hat aber was ist
eigentlich mit den Amerikanern haben sie
mit verschränkten Armen einfach so
daneben gestanden und zugeschaut nun
offensichtlich nicht bei dieser
Geschichte gibt es so einige Gewinner
und Verlierer boeing hat auch Milliarden
von Dollar an us-regierungsgeldern
erhalten und obend drin noch riesige
Sonderkonditionen eine extrem
wohlwollende Behandlung die Berichten
zufolge zeitweise von der
uslftfahrtbehörde FAA selbst kam dies
ist die noch bis vor kurzem hoch
angesehene Behörde die für die
Regulierung und Überwachung aller
Aktivität im Zusammenhang mit der
zivilen Luftfahrt und ihrer Sicherheit
in den Vereinigten Staaten zuständig ist
und ihr fragt euch jetzt sicher was
haben Sie denn gemacht nun die USofA
finanzieren Boeing durch Milliarden
schwere Militär Luft und
raumfahrtverträge von denen viele
glauben dass sie zu überhöhten Preisen
vergeben werden mit anderen Worten es
handelt sich um eine Art versteckte
Subventionierung ich meine seht euch die
Daten nur mal an die größten
Auftragnehmer von Boeing sind keine
geringeren als die NASA das
US-Verteidigungsministerium und das us
Ministerium für innere Sicherheit allein
im Jahr 2017 hat Boeing 23,4 Milliarden
Dollar aus Aufträgen der US-Regierung
verdient wie aus den Daten der General
Services Administration hervorgeht und
tatsächlich behauptet Airbus zu seiner
Verteidigung dass die ständigen und
zahlreichen Aufträge die Boeing von der
US-Regierung und öffentlichen
Einrichtung erhält eine Art
Subventionierung des amerikanischen
luftfahrtriesen
darstellen aber nicht nur das es gibt da
nämlich noch die angebliche
Vorzugsbehandlung durch die FAA seht
euch an FAA sah hohes absturßrisiko ließ
aber Boeing 737 MAX
weiterfliegen die Abstürze der Boeing
737 MAX waren der schreckliche Höhepunkt
einer Reihe fehlerhafter technischer
Annahmen der boeingingenieure eines
Mangels an Transparenz seitens des
Boeing Managements und einer grob
unzureichenden Aufsicht durch die FAA
Bericht des Verkehrs und
infrastrukturausschusses des
usreäsentantenhauses FAA und Boeing
manipulierten 737 MAX Tests während der
Zertifizierung tatsächlich deutet alles
darauf hin dass die USA Boeing nicht nur
jedes Jahr durch verträgegeld zukommen
lassen sondern dem Unternehmen auch mit
einer gewissen Nachlässigkeit bei der
Zertifizierung seiner Flugzeuge helfen
konkret geht es um die 737 MAX ein
Flugzeug das verspätet und schlecht
entwickelt wurde um mit dem Airbus A320
Neo zu konkurrieren dieser kam praktisch
überraschend auf den Markt und Boeing
konnte nicht mit diesem Modell
konkurrieren und falls sich dieser
Verdacht bestätigen sollte kann man nur
sagen dass der Ausgang wahrlich tragisch
war
soweit so schlecht aber es muss nicht
immer um Leben und Tot gehen manchmal
reichen einfach auch
Steueranreize 12 März 2020 der
bundesstat Washington hebt die
Steuererleichterung für Boeing auf die
USA hoffen dadurch eu-zölle zu vermeiden
durch die Änderungen würde die
40przentige Ersparnis bei der Gewerbe
und berufssteuer wegfallen die Boeing im
Jahr 2018 auf der Grundlage der
veröffentlichen jetliner Umsätze rund
118 Milli on Dollar einbrachte handelt
es sich bei diesen Bestimmungen nicht
auch um öffentliche Subventionen die dem
freien Wettbewerb Schaden und sind sie
nicht eine Bevorzugung von Boeing durch
die US-Regierung nun die Wahrheit ist
dass die Welthandelsorganisation nicht
nur gegen Airbus sondern auch gegen die
Amerikaner entschieden hat WTO
entscheidet dass die USA es versäumt
haben unfere Steuervergünstigungen für
Boeing zu stoppen die USA hatten 2012
eine anordnunglich durch gesetzt die
Subvention für den us-fugzeughersteller
durch Steuervergünstigung des
Bundesstaats Washington zu stoppen der
unzulässige wettbsvorteil fühte dazu
dass Airbus die schmalrumfugzeuge A320
Neo und A320 Co im Rahmen von fünf
Verkaufskampagnen nicht mehr absetzen
konnte tja und was die
Korruptionsskandale von Airbus angeht
auch hier hat die Medaille wie üblich
zwei Seiten und die nicht so
offensichtliche Seite ist nun mal dass
die Amis ihre
antikorruptionsgesetzgebung gerne dazu
missbrauchen um ungeliebte Konkurrenten
von US-Unternehmen zu schikanieren indem
sie dabei oft mit zweierlei maßmessen
das liegt sicher aber auch daran dass
die USA eben über viel robustere
antikorruptionsgesetze verfügen als die
EU die aber wiederum härtere Regeln für
wettbewerbsumwelt und Verbraucherschutz
hat und jede Seite setzt eben die Waffen
ein mit denen sie den anderen am besten
trifft also was soll ich sagen beide
Giganten sind schuldig gesprochen misse
Taten begangen zu haben aber eben auf
unterschiedliche Weise es ist also
wieder eine Geschichte in der es weder
richtig gute noch richtig böse Jungs
gibt aber letztenendes ist natürlich
wieder einer der Dumme der Steuerzahler
denn ja es mag vernünftig klingen die
Entwicklung großer technologischer und
industrieller Projekte zu unterstützen
aber vielleicht sollte die Hilfe fairer
begrenzter und für mehr Unternehmen
offen sein oder was meint ihr tatsache
ist dass die Unterzeichnung eines
Handelsabkommen zwischen den USA und
Europa in dieser Frage nicht einfach war
und auch nicht vom Himmel gefallen ist
außerdem gab es einen Faktor der eine
Schlüsselrolle bei der Beendigung des
Krieges zwischen den beiden Unternehmen
und den beiden Blöcken gespielt hat na
könnt ihr erraten was dieser der
schlüssselfaktor war nun hört gut zu
denn er wird euch
überraschen was China zusammengefügt hat
soll niemand mehr
trennen 17 Jahre Krieg zwischen den
beiden Führenden Flugzeugherstellern der
Welt fordern ihren Tribut letztendlich
handelt es sich um etwas dass wir hier
auf visualpolitik oft wiederholen
Handelskriege nutzen normalerweise
keiner Seite und das ist auch im Fall
von Boeing Airbus nicht anders beide
Hersteller haben sich gegenseitig viel
geschadet und damit vielleicht auch der
Entwicklung der ganzen Branche der
Streit zwischen den Vereinigten Staaten
und der Europäischen Union erhöhte die
Import und exportkosten schränkte die
Nutzung und Entwicklung von Technologien
ein und verteuerte letztlich die
Flugzeuge und verlangsamte die
Entwicklung der Branche und wisst ihr
was damit wurde ein idealer Nährboden
für andere geschaffen die versuchen die
unruhigen Gewässer auszunutzen doch
jetzt ist es zu spät der Wolf hat das
Blut gerochen und dieser Wolf heißt
China wir haben uns mit der EU auch
darauf geeinigt gemeinsam gegen Chinas
nicht marktkonforme Praktiken in diesem
Sektor vorzugehen die Chinas Unternehmen
einen unfairen Vorteil verschaffen Joe
Biden das Airbus Boeing dupol könnte
zumindest im kurz und
mittelstreckensegment durch einen neuen
Konkurrenten bedroht werden Chinas
Comac und Pickings ist aggressiv eine
Mischung aus den beiden Formen
staatliche Subventionen ein die wir in
diesem Video gesehen haben nämlich die
der Europäer und die der Amerikaner die
chinesis Regierung subventioniert die
Entwicklung von Flugzeugen direkt und
vergibt über ihre staatlichen
Fluggesellschaften auch große Aufträge
der comake aj21 der bis zu 100
Passagiere befördern kann fliegt bereits
im kommerziellen Einsatz und der Comac
919 befindet sich derzeit auf Testflügen
obwohl es einige Probleme gab und sich
seine Betriebnahme gegenüber dem
Zeitplan von 2023 verzögern konnte blieb
die Tatsache bestehen dass dieses
Flugzeug eine große Bedrohung für die
Zukunft von Boeing und Airbus darstellen
könnte wir sprechen von einem Flugzeug
das bis zu 174 Passagiere befördern kann
und damit in China direkt mit dem A320
und der 737 konkurriert den Flagschiffen
der beiden westlichen Giganten außerdem
rechnet China damit bis 2028 150 dieser
Flugzeuge pro Jahr
herzustellen und dieses Szenario das
eines Flugzeugherstellers für den
chinesischen kurz und
mittelstreckenmarkt wäre der schlimmste
Albtraum für Airbus und Boeing warum
weil China der Schlüsselmarkt für die
Zukunft der beiden luftfahrgiganten ist
nach eigenen Berechnungen von Boeing
wird der asiatische Riese bis 2041 fast
8500 neue Passagierflugzeuge kaufen
müssen tja das ist wahrlich ein
gewaltiger Batzen Kohle und wenn es
einem lokalen Konkurrenten wie comc
gelingt auch nur ein bedeutendes Stück
dieses Kuchens abzubekommen könnte sich
die Zukunft von Boeing und Airbus völlig
verändern Comac würde in das Business
der beiden platzherische einschlagen wie
eine Bombe und deshalb sind sowohl beide
Unternehmen als auch die Regierungen der
Vereinigten Staaten und der Europäischen
Union pragmatisch vorgegangen in den
letzten Jahren haben beide Unternehmen
in China endmontagelinien für einige
ihrer begehrtesten Modelle wie die
Boeing 737 den Airbus 320 und den A321
Neo eröffnet außerdem hat die EU den USA
vorgeschlagen die sogenannte Starthilfe
für Airbus zu beenden und das Konsortium
im Gegenzug durch Militärausgaben zu
finanzieren und dass es damit so richtig
losgeht können wir bereits sehen Spanien
stellt Airbus 2,14 Milliarden Euro für
militärprogramme zu Z Verfügung tja wie
viele von euch vielleicht schon erkannt
haben wird damit praktisch das
amerikanische Modell der Finanzierung
von Boeing durch die Europäer übernommen
gegen das Brüssel seit 17 Jahren
gekämpft hat na ja es ist ja nicht
ungewöhnlich dass europäische Politiker
ihre Meinung ändern
müssen bisher ist nur bekannt dass beide
Blöcke die EU und die USA einen
Waffenstillstand in diesem Handelskrieg
unterzeichnet haben so dass dieser
theoretisch vor 2026 beendet sein sollte
und die Zukunft nun wir können es nicht
mit Sicherheit wissen aber klar ist dass
weder Airbus noch Boeing in der Lage
sind sich über unlauteren Wettbewerb zu
beschweren die beiden Industriegiganten
haben enorme Geldbeträge aus der
Staatskasse erhalten kontrollieren beide
mehr oder weniger einen ähnlich großen
Marktanteil und verfügen über enorme
politische Verbindungen zum stat tja und
an dieser Stelle seid erstmal ihr an der
Reihe glaubt ihr das Airbus und Boeing
endgültig Frieden schließen werden
sollten die beiden Unternehmen
zusammenarbeiten um die Chinesen daran
zu hindern auf dem Markt Fuß zu fassen
was denkt ihr wie der Krieg um die
Kontrolle des Luftraums in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten aussehen wird schreibt uns
eure Einschätzung bitte in den
Kommentarbereich unter diesem Video und
vergesst bitte auch nicht auf meinem
neuen Kanal vorbeizuschauen den ich euch
ebenfalls in der Videobeschreibung
verlinke ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleichtwas
dabei gelernt habt Fall ja gibt uns
bitte ein Like teilt mit euren Freunden
und diskutiert es mit ihnen natürlich
freuen wir jederzeit eine Spende von
euch mit uns dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
auch in der Videobeschreibung macht's
gut und bis bald
[Musik]